j'ai des petites photos de vous deux
vous des chroniqueurs quand il était
bébé alors vous allez trouver de qui il
s'agit chez vous aussi regarder on est
on dirait que c'est le 1er novembre
plein premiers chroniqueurs c'est qui ça
premiers chroniqueurs premiers
chroniqueurs
merci de ses marques la régie des génies
mon père il est sur la photo
j'avais à mes beaux ils sont pris la
tête à même la peau tons et tous ses
recours
oui alors oui voilà c'est donc quand
j'étais jeune souriant j'avais un prof
si moi j'ai l'impression
je dit ça j'ai l'impression qu'elle voue
au tiff ah oui mais on tour à la tendre
enfance et ce à quoi si on avait un
enfant ensemble peut-être qu'il sera
aussi est jolie mais les lieux au moment
où m et puis maintenant bien sa part
alors on vient de me dire dans
l'oreillette qu'en fait on jouera pas à
ce qu'ils ont mis les noms surtout on va
casser génie les genevois
bah voilà il s'appelle sur noir et blanc
[Applaudissements]
il a alors écrit mais vous vous êtes
mignonne mamère fois ci non mais c'est
vrai allez vous vous posez vous lisiez
un peu dans les lignes de la main gauche
voilà vous avez jusqu'à la fin aucune
idée j'ai mes chattes bien mais elle est
bien évidemment vous n'êtes plus dans
les poches louis n'avait pas changé
avant non franchement mienne non
franchement elle a même petit j'aurais
reconnu direct allez on a c'est qu'il
prochain faites votre vie maintenant
voilà géraldine lectorat sera là
à cet âge-là bray décalages et nous
vient de recevoir un livre trois ans
elle vient de lire le dernier costard
lala vient de finir un bouquin la roja
sera alors sur nîmes en plus c'est vrai
c'est ouf 0,78 ah ouais ouais de 78 ans
était déjà vous lisiez des et j'écoutais
elle a trois ans elle a le plus de
l'escaut mois maintenant
tiens on va voir le prochain venu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'on va retrouver ce soir sur w9
hills elle était déjà il permis non on
peut en voir ils savent que je kiffe
hisse à la tête elle est trop mignonne
mais ça va revenir et noir il est trop
mignon est trop mignon à les prochains
c'est qu'il a retrouvé la photo mais là
on a été chez un gars le gas et
chanteuse dans un grenier il a retrouvé
une diapositive c'est qu'avant la guerre
sa femme il n a pas la peine d'aller à
l'école alors à toute attaque crottes de
zen joli but mais c'est pas grave ça
arrive il y en aura en laponie ajout
unités - 27 ans d'affaires avec façon là
bas ils savent que quand même ça se
galochent ils savent qu'à la creuse et
je me suis rangé
merci en tout cas je vous prends je vous
remets ton style pas mais dehors allez
alors on y va
yakhi away delphine déjà les allées
propre contenu moyen des photos de moi
même quand je suis petit j'ai toujours
une tâche d'huile comme une pâte ici non
mais ça je te l'eau et des tunisiens tu
vois toit retiré elle est mignonne tu
vas passer
oui mais là je vais avoir un nom je
pense en tant qu'homme salon la wii mais
dis moi je faisais cette taille là
j'avais 8 ans
ben non là bas au niveau de la frange
sais pas ce qui s'est passé parce qu'il
ya effet il lâché ou alors c'est de la
lacc peuvent essayer de vous taire cinq
minutes merci allez on y va
le prochain arrêt ah oui bah s'est mis à
les mignonnes 1% vos morceaux bly et
d'année vous avez quel âge là bas
c'était avant la révolution russe et
ancienne copine non et blanc aussi drôle
berne et bernard mais bernard montiel me
plaît quoi avec quatre ans c'était en
1961 ah ouais mais j'en rigole on dirait
que tu vas faire un casting et
illumineront la chemise ali ben ouais on
dirait film déjà avec leurs une plage
c'est vrai on dirait vraiment le gars il
est comateux macacos je viens de lire le
dernier de ce thonidé sud en mai il est
trés c'est le plus beau pour l'instant
bernard montiel a rien à dire il est
niée bout il va mourir beau alaoui non
mais je te jure sur une plage à
casablanca ça veut dire sénat père qu'on
s'en fout totalement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
frérot a way that été ouvertes au local
est sorti il amène à roissy n'est fermée
mais je vous jure elle a été réalisée
son truc hein parce que tu as fait ton
des risques a fait un truc sur google
non c'est le vrai gars je vais frère
alors soraya égard mon ami cela met fin
lorsque j'arrive pas ce que c'était
alors franchement et d'urbanistes ut ça
va beaucoup mieux il est hyper boys la
tête de ma mère l'obstétricien et là
tout va bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le journal au contraire dans une rue
étroite et saison il ferme les volets
franchement il dit je crois pour moi
peut être le plus sympathique de la
bande hrebec 71 vous avez quel âge là
j'ai quelques mois pas tout à fait un an
non mais pourquoi est-ce qu la honte a
parlé d'un programme vous vendent parce
qu'en fait quand j'étais petit j'étais
tellement énervé que je tapais la tête
contre les murs non m'éloignais du mur
je n'étais pas content je voulais le mur
adacore vous l'aï appris depuis le mur
là vous l'avez pris et bien pris un an
mais si c'est ou ça horrible on va
terminer je pense que c'était la
dernière année encore trois bateaux et
on continue parce que là c est la bad
est là la chaux parages santé mentale
maes et chantal de chine là on à faire
tu étais font la fête est finie
est-ce que tu t'en fous tu âge la marche
est là déjà ça commence c'était des
boîtes a toujours été belle si chantal
tu es toujours m'a demandé ça cinq
heures le temps je trouve la photo sera
compte passer à travers un iphone d'un
iphone d'un à l'ol oui oui oui leur
écoute barcelone
[Applaudissements]
il est minuit les plombs comme elle
échoue on dirait un petit garçon qui a
tari pub pour du fromage en rigoler
c'est pour dupont dupond du bruit hier
mais du bouclier et vous étiez déjà
marié la clause la vie ballon devenu
ballon balancé était déjà fini j'étais
là un mec juste en train de mettre à
coups de son prêt à que 1600 gagner mais
j'étais très vilain je suis resté au
mignon non non non non non n'osant pas
trop c'est comme ça ouais j'ai toujours
été et venir voilà merci en tout cas
gilles vous nous avez fait la soirée